welcome to the world of digital
marketing where success thrives on a
dynamic blend of creativity strategy and
innovation in this tutorial by simply
learn we will unveil the essential
arsenal of skills that will Empower you
to conquer the digital landscape from
the art of captivating storytelling to
the science of datadriven decision
making we will guide you through the
strategies and techniques that can
Propel your brand product or service to
new heights online whether you're are a
seasoned marketer looking to level up or
just beginning your journey this video
will equip you with the top digital
marketing skills to harness the immense
potential of digital age that said if
these are the type of videos you'd like
to watch then hit that subscribe button
and the bell icon to get notified as we
speak you might be wondering how to
become a certified professional and back
your dream job in this to me if you are
a professional with minimum one year of
experience and an aspiring digital
marketing professional looking for
online training and certifications from
the prestigious universities and in
collaboration with leading experts then
search no more simply learns
postgraduate program and digital
marketing from Caltech University in
collaboration with meta and stent should
be your right choice for more details
head straight to our homepage and search
for postgraduate program in digital
marketing from Pur University or simply
click on the link in the description box
below now without further delay over to
our training digital marketing a dynamic
and everchanging discipline comprises a
vast area of skills and strategies
essential for promoting products
services or Brands effectively in the
online realm success in this field
hinges on cultivating a diverse skill
set that enables you to adapt to the
evolving landscape it demands a keen
understanding of emerging ing
Technologies data analytics and consumer
Behavior as well as Proficiency in P of
Technologies such as SEO content
marketing social media management paid
advertising and much more navigating
this multifaceted landscape empowers
digital marketers to craft compelling
campaigns reach wider audiences and stay
at the Forefront of digital Frontier so
without further delay let's get started
with the top digital marketing skills
that you you need in this domain to rank
on top so the first one is SEO or search
engine optimization search engine
optimization is the practice of
optimizing websites and online content
to enhance their visibility on search
engine result Pages or S
RPS this involves improvising factors
such as the keyword relevance website
structure and quality of content to rank
higher in organic search results SEO
helps businesses increase their online
prisons attract more organic traffic and
ultimately attract potential customers
to their websites It encompasses on page
and off-page techniques including
keyword research link building and
Technical optimization SEO is an ongoing
process as search engine algorithms
evolve requiring continuous efforts to
maintain and improve ranking moving
ahead we have content marketing content
marketing is a strategic approach to
digital marketing that involves creating
and distributing valuable relevant and
consistent content to attract and engage
a target audience this content can take
a various forms such as blog posts
articles videos infographics and much
more the primary goal is to provide
information entertain or evolve problems
for the audience building trust and
credibility with the brand effective
content marketing can drive organic
traffic generate leads and ultimately
convert prospects into loyal customers
it plays a vital role in establishing a
Brand's Authority enhancing its online
presence and nurturing long-term
customer relationships next is social
media marketing social media marketing
is a digital marketing strategy that
leverages social media platforms such as
Facebook Twitter Instagram and Linkedin
to promote products services or Brands
it involves creating and sharing
engaging content running paid
advertising campaigns and interacting
with thep Market audience to build brand
awareness Drive website traffic and
generate leads or sales smm is essential
for connecting with a vast and diverse
online audience fostering engagement and
monitoring performance through analytics
successful social media marketing
strategies are tailored to each platform
taking into account other user
demographics and behavior to achieve
marketing objectives effectively next is
email Market marketing email marketing
is a digital marketing strategy that
involves sending targeted messages to a
group of recipents via email it is a
powerful tool for businesses to engage
with their audience promote products
share valuable content and build
customer relationships effective email
marketing requires creating compelling
and relevant content segmenting email
list and using authorization automation
to send personalized messages it's
essential to ADH here to best practices
including obtaining permission from
recipents optin providing easy
unsubscribed options and ensuring emails
are mobile friendly tracking and
analyzing email campaign performance is
the key to optimizing results and
achieving marketing goals next in the
list is pay Blick or PPC advertising PPC
advertising is an online advertising
model where advertisers pay a fee each
time their ad is clicked or a user is
landing on their landing page it's
commonly used on search engines like
Google and social media platforms
advertisers bit on keywords and when a
user's search query matches those
keywords the ad is displayed PPC allows
businesses to Target specific audiences
control their budget and measure the
effectiveness of their campaigns through
click through rates and conversion data
it offers a cost-effective way to drive
immediate traffic to websites making it
a valuable tool in digital marketing
strategies sixth one on the list is
analytics and data analysis analytics
and data analysis in digital marketing
involve extracting actionable insights
from past data sets of data to inform
strategic decisions it encompasses
tracking and interpreting key
performance indicators kpis user
behavior and website metrics using tools
like Google Analytics
by examining data marketers can optimize
campaigns improve user experiences and
fine-tune strategies for better results
data analysis AIDS in understanding
audiences preferences refining targeting
and measuring the return on investment
of marketing efforts it's a crucial
skill for datadriven marketing enabling
businesses to make informed choices and
continuously improve their online
presence now the seventh one in the list
is conversion rate optimization
conversion rate optimization is a
systematic process of enhancing a
website or marketing campaign to
maximize the percentage of visitors who
take desired actions such as making a
purchase signing up or filling out a
form it involves AP testing user
Behavior Analysis and strategic
improvements to design content and user
experience the goal is to increase
conversions and subsequently revenue or
leads without increasing traffic cro
helps businesses make datadriven
decisions and enhance the efficiency of
their digital marketing efforts
resulting in improved Roi and a better
user experience for website visitors now
the next one in the list is marketing
automation marketing automation is the
use of software and Technology to
streamline and automate marketing tasks
and processes it helps businesses
efficiently manage customer relationship
nurture leads and deliver personalized
content at scale by automating email
campaigns lead scores and customer
segmentation marketing automation
enhances engagement saves time and
improves overall marketing strategy it
also enables data driven decision making
through detailed analytics allowing
businesses to tailor their Market
efforts and Achieve higher return on
investment ultimately marketing
automation enhances the customer
experience and helps businesses Target
Their audience with Rel relent content
resulting in more effective and
personalized marketing campaigns next is
affiliate marketing affiliate marketing
is a performance-based online marketing
strategy where businesses reward
individuals or Affiliates for performing
other products or Services Affiliates
earn a commission for each sale click or
lead generated through their referral
efforts they use unique tracking links
to trace their referrals and this model
benefits businesses by expanding their
reach and Affiliates by providing a
revenue Source without the need to
create or own products it's a
costeffective way for companies to reach
wider audiences and for Affiliates to
monetize their online presence affiliate
marketing thrives on Partnerships
transparency and the alignment of
interest between businesses and
Affiliates now the last one but also the
important one mobile marketing mobile
marketing is a digital advertising
strategy focused on reaching and
engaging consumers through mobile
devices such as smartphones and tablets
it encompasses various tactics including
SMS marketing mobile app advertising and
mobile optimized websites mobile
marketing leverages the ubiquity of
mobile devices to deliver targeted
messages promotions and content to users
on the goo making it a highly effective
way to connect with your audience it
requires strategies like location based
targeting and responsive design to
provide seamless user experience while
marketing is crucial in today's digital
landscape as an increasing number of
people access internet and make purchase
decisions through their mobile devices
in addition to these core skills it's
important to have a strong understanding
of broader digital marketing ecosystem
staying updated with industry Trends and
Technologies and the ability to adapt to
aoling platforms and strategies keep in
mind that digital marketing is a dynamic
field so ongoing learning and adaption
are essential for success with that we
have come to an end of this top digital
marketing skills tutorial by simply Lo
and with that we have reached to the end
of this session on top digital marketing
skills should you need any assistance
BPD and other resources used in this
session please let us know in the
comment section below and our te of
experts will be happy to help you as
soon as possible until next time thank
you keep learning and stay for more from
Simply love staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to ner up and get certified click
here